this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by ritual and stitch fix
more on that later let's get into the do
the honeydew
with ryan sickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it
in the night pants studios i am ryan
sickler ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on
all social media look
do me a favor make sure you are
subscribed to the youtube channel i love
all of you out there watching commenting
please subscribe also make sure if you
want extra honeydew and you want to be
part of the patreon community
you can subscribe there as well if you
sign up for a year you'll save on over a
month of free episodes
um it is a wild show we are hearing some
crazy [ __ ] from y'all out there you have
not let me down i told ash when we
started like
dude we cast this net out here i don't
know what the [ __ ] we're gonna get
we're we're getting we're getting some
[ __ ] all right that thing is growing
it's only five bucks a month
um so sign up and if you or someone you
know has
that story that needs to be heard please
submit honeydewpodcast
gmail.com all right i record here at the
santa monica music center so if you or
anyone you know
needs musical lessons musical
instruments
your kids santa monica music centers the
spot they've got the online classes now
go to santa monicamusic.com
use the code honeydew they'll waive the
registration fee and they'll give you a
free lesson when you sign up for a
package all right
now that that's out of the way um you
know we do over here
we highlight the low lights these are
the stories behind the storytellers
like to shed a little light on that
darkness and today
it is a pleasure to have this gentleman
in here uh formerly
a crab feast guest with a great episode
please welcome
first time just robert thompson oh yeah
here i am ryan sickler it's the honeydew
oh man i was hoping you would do it oh
he's coming out of the gate swinging
yeah man it is so good to have you good
to see you and
this is a voice i'll be doing voices to
deflect my pain
honeydew yeah
man you're giving me so many sound drops
honeydew
you know what josh robert thompson his
pain probably isn't even good enough to
be on this show
like i get worried about like in my
career that my work isn't good enough
this is the first time i've ever been
really worried that my trauma isn't
going to be as good
i'm sure you're saying because i watch
some of these episodes you got some
[ __ ] up people like
come on no doubt no doubt and
but it's also a perspective thing
because you can
sometimes i sit here and i think to
myself often i'm like what am i [ __ ]
complaining about right you know what i
mean it right and then i hear other
people and i'm like
this is this is your fun that's trauma
right yeah that's what i've been for
for a whole week i've been racking my
brain like i gotta come up with
something good
you're from cleveland it's off to a
great start starts right away starts
right away right when you're born in
cleveland
that's the trauma um well before we get
into all this
please uh plug everything and anything
you'd like
well i know if you still do websites you
can go to
thejrtshow.com that's the
show.com your one-stop shop for josh
robert thompson
my mom always gets the site wrong is it
so jrt.com
no it's the t-h-e-j-r-t show.com
someone else took jrt show somebody for
real dude
on purpose now it's going for like
twenty five hundred dollars
so [ __ ] you whoever you are jrt.com
no mom the jrtshow.com the jrt you can
find
all right um you know if you haven't
heard uh josh's crab feast episode it's
a great [ __ ] episode there's a
hardcore group that listens to the
episodes
yours yours is always picked as a fave
they love the characters
um you know you were just i i mean you
had the dj
there's so many oh the d kenny logan
kenny k log
k-l-o-g all kenny all the time coming up
we got a continuous four-hour block of
kenny we call it the log jam here's a
little danger zone to get you home
here's kenny
and that's all they play that's and then
he'll be like
he'll be like heavy long traffic traffic
is backed up on the 405.
be careful out there you might say it's
a danger zone here's kenny
just no matter what i'm glad you love
that man that's my favorite it's one of
those that stands out
man yeah they're great that's great
stuff
and i told ash ash got all excited
because i go you know who josh is he's
like that's what you say but he's
younger
and i go titty sprinkles he's like nah
oh he knew
yeah the everybody knows titties
sprinkles yeah everybody knows titties
well that was
uh i sometimes do the morgan freeman
voice and uh there he goes
and there was a meme going around that
said something like uh right now when
you're reading this
picture you're seeing you sound like you
feel like you sound like morgan freeman
or something like that
and then it says titty sprinkles at the
end i don't know what they are
but i'm sure they taste good i'll bet
you they taste oh i know they sound like
heaven
josh are you gonna do this voice to make
his pain
sound poetic you know what i mean yeah
cause you say [ __ ] like josh was born uh
off 117th in cleveland ohio
a rough neighborhood where people would
you know sick dogs on them just for fun
yeah i'll never forget
[Music]
let me ask josh real quick did that
really happen that really happened
let's uh let's get into your story yeah
please
cleveland born yeah cleveland-born off
117th and florian fiddy bunny wants to
go down to that neighborhood and go go
stop by visit say hi to the folks over
there in fact i was back there a couple
years ago just decided to take a stroll
down my old street
and i was marveling at all the houses
these houses were built in like 1901.
beautiful old houses we lived up on the
top floor me my mom and my stepdad
and then downstairs was the landlord mrs
van duzer this little old lady almost 90
years old
and uh but i'm in my old neighborhood a
couple years ago walking down the street
and i see my house
and there's a woman taking groceries out
of her car
and she sees me kind of looking at the
house and she takes a look at me gives
me a once-over
and says uh are you lost
so i was like well no i used to live
here ma'am
my name is josh robert thompson i come
from uh los angeles the big city you
know i grew up up there in that house
that you live in you know
but she said the neighborhood was okay
it's okay now
but back when i lived there this was in
the 80s
i got my ass beat like on a daily basis
i'll bet just
yeah in fact one time in eighth grade
i remember the this girl shared a locker
or she had a locker next to mine
and unprovoked unprovoked she looked at
me and said
you know you just look like the kind of
guy that people want to beat up
i don't know hate your face i don't know
what that means
but that's that's my story
all right so are you are you an only
child i am
okay and you're you i was a latch key
kid did they still use that word anymore
no but i was too we wanted to do a tour
a while back called the latch geek
oh yeah yeah i mean everybo you can't
even do that [ __ ] now you [ __ ] have
some latch key kids on the low key that
you got to do it but
they'll [ __ ] set you up for that [ __ ]
oh is that right you can't be centered
you can't do that anymore
by himself yeah go home you'll be fine
by the way the house was so old i had an
actual skeleton key to get in the house
but are you serious really old metal
take the bus he'll take the rapid
transit it'll be fine
yeah i see that key people like we don't
want any part of that it's true man
start let my daughter have a key like
that you should do it i mean it was an
actual skeleton key i think the house
was probably haunted and uh
i got beat up all the time i went the
school i went to
here's a clue as to what was going on
the name of my school was
urban community school oh come on
the ucs the ucs what was your math
just put an f in front of it
we do it all the time hey man welcome to
urban community school man today's the
first day of school
that was one of the students that was
like third grade you know
my buddies were uh antoine houston
froggy arturo and richard stankovic
these were my buddies german indoors
he was one of these guys like i you know
i had to either go home
by myself uh because my parents were
both working
or i had to go stay at friends houses
and the neighborhoods that they lived in
were like you know rusted out
uh trucks in the front yard pit bulls
there were a group of kids that were
always setting [ __ ] on fire in this
alleyway there was never a day that went
by that there wasn't something on fire
in the alleyway kids piss it off the
roof
for real yeah it sounds like a [ __ ] up
norman rockwell
painting i feel like i should garrison
keeler should be narrating
it's a beautiful day in cleveland ohio
josh robert thompson's the young boys 10
years
old and he's about to get his ass beat
by chris regan
the grandson of the regan family down
the street but chris regan was an
affable bully he gave you a choice
he said things like i can either punch
in the face
or kick you in the stomach
that's true he goes he goes
imagine this choice okay listen man
oh god i wish i could say what he really
said but there was a word in the 80s
that everybody just said you know uh
very homophobic homophobic now but it's
a word we all use that was not you know
but this guy was like
okay man you got a choice and he had a
little guy i swear this is like out of a
christmas story which by the way is
where they shot a lot of a christmas
story oh is that right part of town okay
like go watch that movie again and you
go
i just watched that's exactly what that
neighborhood looked like okay
untouched his stooly his little guy yeah
see
he like held my arms behind my back
to keep me in play i was a little guy i
was just i wasn't fighting back
i was not into fighting a very passive
artist kid drew cartoons and wrote poems
i didn't you know
chris regan says all right i'm going to
give you a choice
because i like you i don't know what
like i either punch you in the face or
kick you in the stomach
10 year old me has to reason yeah these
are your choices and i was like well
i don't really want my face [ __ ] up
why don't you go for the stomach and
this guy with
everything he had kicked me as hard as
he could
i could [ __ ] kill you i thought
houdini died
so who's he used to shoot the
cannonballs yeah i i don't know who he
was that was me
i've seen him i was 10 years old that
guy didn't work out for me i was like
you know in a ball on the ground on the
sidewalk man
but um that neighborhood was very
very strange it was a mix it was a lot
of black
uh puerto rican and then
you know for lack of a better word just
trash just
it's a real trashy kind of neighborhood
you know we were trying to get out of
there and for a while
before my step-dad came along okay so
all right my real father left i never
met him so he was out of the picture
did he leave before you were actually
born or right after he left uh right
after i was born i believe
so because of you yeah
[Music]
in fact he said in fact
the doctor said this is according to my
my mom told me that the doctor
said when i was born they said that my
dad
turned to my mom and said you know he
just looks like the kind of kid that
people want to beat
want to punch up let's give him a choice
do we punch him in the face or kick him
in the stomach
he gave my mom that choice before i was
born
tell you what honey i can either punch
you in the face or kick in his stomach
so he was out of the picture and there
was a period of time where it was just
me and my mom
together until i was like five okay i
mean we were poor
poor we were on welfare food stamps
this was this was not a i mean urban
community school
by the way was a great is a great school
now
it was started in the late 60s by a
group group of nuns
so it was all nuns running the school
but they it was for uh low-income
students you know uh uh but that school
you know it was so tough there that
every summer you had to take your desk
pick up your desk it was one of those
big metal desks with the top on it and
it had the little ledge inside for your
pencils and the girls would fill that
with elmer's glue
because it was kind of the shape of a
nail and they would make fake nails out
of elmer's glue i remember oh [ __ ] okay
that's my garrison keeler voice again it
was a golden summer
the girls would make nails out of
elmer's glow
just a beautiful day so dude we had to
take
our desks those heavy ass desks
nine-year-old kids
and carry them down two flights of steps
to the parking lot where we had recess
and scrub them clean
because kids would you know draw on them
and graffiti yeah
so we had to clean this [ __ ] yeah just
imagine like a line of little kids
come on students chop chop you know
sister francis mary and i mean they were
they were tough
if you got in trouble you you know you
get slapped on the wrist with a ruler
this is real catholic school you know
but this was the
this was the school where um the first
day
i was so nervous about going to that
school and i got beat up so much and i
was terrified to go there i wanted to
get out of there
and it was just a nightmare for me to go
there uh that i was so nervous that one
morning i was about to start fifth grade
and i told my mom i don't feel well i
got a stomachache she says well it's
just your nerves honey you'll be fine
have some pepto-bismol that was the old
yeah
the old cure so i took pepto-bismol i
felt all right
she said you know you need to eat you
probably need to eat
not addressing the real issue everything
is something else it's probably you're
just nervous you need to eat so
i had um a strawberry uh pop-tart
breakfast for champions right yeah nice
layer of sugar and cake and sprinkles
there's a theme here pepto-bismol
strawberry pop-tart i wash it down with
uh
nestle's uh strawberry quick
right all pink a lot of out of paint
yeah yeah
all sloshing around in there and so josh
i can't help it man it just makes it
sound so beautiful
so josh got in the car and his mother
drove him to school as she often did
and that morning he felt things would be
different
somehow this time he had it in the bag
he was going to walk in there victorious
he was going to take on the school year
he was going to come out the other end a
hero
he kissed his mother goodbye and marched
proudly into the
cafeteria which was the assembly area
for the morning
with the entire student body gathered
everybody that josh would see for the
entire year
was in one room
and josh began to feel his stomach
gurgle
and he thought oh that just must be the
pop-tart settling a little bit
maybe nestle quicker saying hello to me
but he didn't pay no mind and the
teachers began to present the
daily activities and josh suddenly got
the sweats
and his face turned as white as snow and
he fell to his knees
in the middle of everybody in that
auditorium
wearing his members only jacket in his
e.t
backpack
[Music]
what a kick the e.t backpack boot
full display while he's on his knees
he set his e.t backpack next to him
gently
his velcro tennis shoes
and it's important to note that he had
patches on his jeans
they didn't have a lot of money back
then and his mother
although a wonderful woman was not
exactly
the best seamstress you see she put the
patches
on the outside of the jeans and not on
the inside
so that's that's the image
um the students closest to josh began to
notice that he was on his knees
and so they backed away slowly and
formed a large circle around josh
so everybody could watch and wait and
see what was going to happen
and then josh threw up everything that
he had that morning
the pepto-bismol the strawberry pop-tart
and the strawberry quick
all laid out in front of him and
i threw up in front of everybody on the
first day of fifth grade
and i'll never forget this little black
girl who was standing right next to me
she had a lollipop in her mouth
and she had those pigtails she had the
braids that were the
the plastic balls the hard and she took
the
lollipop out of her but i'll never
forget and she said
she pointed to me she gestured to me
like you might like if someone says hey
where's the gas station you go
yeah it's over there that's how she
gestured to a human she went like this
that boy puked it
[Laughter]
so
oh boy
so for about two weeks i was
affectionately known as a puke boy
hey there goes that kid that threw up in
front of old school
i mean that i think that is the
summation
of my entire life that moment right
there
you know and uh i went back to that
school not long ago i actually visited a
few years ago oh god damn
and i and some lady i had some very nice
lady was
cleaning up mopping one of the floors it
was summertime so there was no school in
session and
i said hi i just [ __ ] hi i used to i
used to go to school here and she's like
yeah i okay do you mind if i look around
i guess so
i didn't give a [ __ ] and and uh you know
it looks exactly the same
it looks exactly no improvements no this
is the 80s
yeah and i don't think it's actually
they moved urban community school
uh to a nice facility it's actually like
a very
well-known school now so it's they
actually realized their dream of what
they wanted it to be which was a nice
facility for low-income students so
that's nice to hear
yeah but it wasn't that when i went
there you know and um
[Music]
it was just it was rough man it was a
rough rough and my step-dad
was kind of a tough guy and he comes in
it you said eight five i found that okay
yeah
and how what did he do how did your mom
meet him well
i don't know exactly i i i think they
probably met at a bar
what did your mom do she's a nurse a
nurse okay
she's a saint so she's out hustling as a
single mom yeah
providing you're going to this school
you're getting [ __ ] up
and you don't have a male influence in
your life right and at five you get here
comes this guy
this beast of a man with his big to me
you know when you're a kid
big beard who's this and he was all of
like 25 or 26. this was a guy that was
like
busy hard drinking you know he was an
alcoholic
you know flipping cars he got in real
bar fights where like a guy kicked his
eye in with a steel-toed boot
i mean it all sounds fake but this is
what he that's how he grew up
right and his what are you complaining
about right
that's exactly it yeah like his dad
um he was passed away
a long time ago now but his dad you know
my grandfather was
uh a world war ii
[Music]
fighter pilot like he dropped bombs like
when they were men
duty he has a leather jacket the the
fighting devil squadron
there's a devil embroidered on the back
my dad has the jacket still and it's
like this it's got the mustache
and the thing and then it has
embroidered all the bombs he dropped
there's like 20 bombs
holy [ __ ] like their little like the
college helmets with right
right look what i did today honey and
here he comes he's dropped a 13th bomb
holy [ __ ] like you're saying he's a real
man you know and those guys came back
from the war and they're like what are
you complaining about
i flew a plane those old planes i don't
know how this guy did it
so that was his dad and so like uh he
was
he was tough on me uh because i think he
was young
and i think the way that he grew up was
tough
and so like for example the way that i
learned to tell time
uh he sat me down in the kitchen and he
said
you're gonna sit here until you learn to
tell time
and then he took the clock off the wall
took the batteries out of the back of it
and then he would change the hour and
minute hand and just go what time is it
what time is it and i'd be like oh
no 5 30.
again what time is it i don't know
but i learned you know how long it took
me three hours and 26 minutes
i don't know
i learned how to ride a bike um
this is bad and i love him i do he's
he's the man
are they still together they're not
they're not okay but he's still in your
life he's still in my life good
and uh he's a cool dude man and
he taught me how to ride a bike i didn't
know any different you know i didn't
know this was
how things probably shouldn't be done
but every time i fell off the bike
he would do the pick me up by the arm
and spank me
get back on the goddamn bike i can't i
keep falling you're gonna learn this
and i learned how to ride a [ __ ] bike
you know now you tell people that story
now and they go oh
jesus christ are you okay like my mom
every
my mom can't hear that story because she
thinks honey
do you need help do you need to i'm fine
you know we we joke about
it he and i joke about it but i mean
that was the kind of
so how long how old was your mom he's 25
they're the same same age
so how long are they together well they
were married for
20 oh wow 27 years 23 24 all through
your school
yeah yeah okay yeah so they got divorced
later in my life
you know i was like 30 or so
but um you know it was
uh it was jus i mean he was he was very
supportive of my
of my wanting to be an artist i mean
he's he was like big he's big into
sports i mean i grew up in cleveland
you know it's either like you're in the
sports or you're in the military
or you you must be something wrong with
you you know he was out there fixing
cars all the time and
you know i think he tried his best and
he was definitely proud of me i mean i
did plays at the cleveland play house
which at the time was a big
big deal i was nine years old and i did
all these big plays there you know and i
definitely wanted to be an actor
but in that you know in cleveland has a
uh
cleveland has an interesting philosophy
about these things it's like uh like the
late late show which we'll get to but i
did the late late show with craig
ferguson for years
and then the show ended yeah and then
people in cleveland would say
you know it's too bad it ended but i
mean you know if you do nothing else
at least you did that yeah and can you
imagine if i said that to like a factory
worker like
well you worked at the factory for 30
years and it's closed down
and if you never work another job again
i mean at least you had that one job
i mean it's what the [ __ ] hey
if you never eat again you know at least
she ate that one time oh that one
what are you talking about
but that is the that's what i grew up
with like don't don't try too hard and
like
and don't be proud of your work and
that's too much if you get lucky then
consider yourself a winner right yeah
but but don't
but don't be too loud about it keep it
to yourself like a catholic growing up
in a catholic alcoholic family
you keep everything to yourself
everything don't make a big deal out of
what you do
you know so even when i moved to la my
friends were like all right that's
enough for that when are you coming back
enough for la la land yeah what are you
even doing over there
that's what people ask me by the way my
fans are the best i love them but i mean
they're tacked they're bedside men are
maybe not the best
if you read some of the comments
recently you'd think that i had died
like i
i was on the kelly clarkson show a
couple months ago i do voice over stuff
for them
i've been working since the late late
show one off the air but not on anything
that people
know about a family guy well that they
don't you know they don't like people
see
uh kelly clarkson and they go i
heard you on the kelly clarkson show i'm
so glad you're finally doing something
what the [ __ ] been six years
finally like all my fans are like my mom
i am it's just a bunch of my moms
are you okay do you need money do you
know honey
but that was uh you know then we moved
we moved to the suburbs
uh we got the hell out of that
neighborhood we moved out of there i
mean
probably 86 okay when i moved to parma
the suburbs of cleveland much nicer nice
little house
half an acre of land you know all right
go out there mow the lawn
it'll take you 10 minutes yeah first
full day of work
what um do you and if so what age do you
start wanting to know about your
biological father i mean are you
was your mom up front with you about
this from the get-go or did you
present it and then she started talking
to you yeah yeah i did i did wonder
about
because he was spoken about in hushed
tones it was the thing we don't talk
about
you know yeah your father did you know
his parents
no no relationships i didn't i didn't
meet any of those none of that
he was he was uh i don't i still don't
fully know the entire story to be honest
with you and i all i
what i know is he wasn't able to see me
or he wasn't allowed to see me
or prison sounds pretty sounds like a
sort of mental prism
yeah i mean and i found out you know
that
he uh had moved to
san francisco and i didn't i didn't
think anything of it
he said yeah he moved to san francisco
okay and uh i'd always wanted to meet my
real father
and as i got older i started to ask the
questions probably by the time
i was in you know early high school okay
i was like who who is this guy is he
still around can i meet him
well you know i don't know if it's a
good idea i know my mom would say i
don't think it's a good idea you know i
don't
i don't know if you're ready for that
yet and um so she she could locate him
if she needed to or she knew where his
whereabouts yeah
and i would get these cards occasionally
okay from this
woman who said she was my other grandma
birthday cards occasionally i'd get a
card and it would say
we miss you we love you i don't know who
these people are so it was weird to read
that and then it would say give us a
call here's my phone number
and i was just too afraid to call i
didn't i couldn't really i didn't
understand
who this person was and then uh
this is the hor this is the way i found
out that my dad died
okay 1990
i'm 15 years old um uh and
this is back when you had to go look
through your dad's [ __ ] to find
porn so he had an amazing
uh penthouse magazine collection
but what i was looking for was the
penthouse forum which was the smaller
book
of just stories like made-up story like
total [ __ ] stories like
i was working at the gas station and all
of a sudden these two [ __ ] came in
and they're saying i know they're
sucking my dick you know
five pages of that that [ __ ] s
you hit
right it's some of my favorite [ __ ] dude
hey man
i was walking down the street i was on
euclid avenue i was just minding my
business you know
you know i know so many people from
baltimore to talk like that
by the way ivy man just as a quick aside
i'm glad you like that because
i do that voice out of love i grew up
hearing this type of voice yeah it is
music to me dude
it is like when i hear that i'm like ugh
i've heard you so many times back home
never out here never out here we had a
guy that lived next door to me in
cleveland his name was
rolo i never heard a brother named rolo
his his friend would always pull up on a
motorcycle
which was always weird because i never
saw a brother on a motorcycle and he'd
be like
hey rolo hey hey yo
rolo hey rolo
hey like five minutes
yeah hey man and then you'd hear it
[ __ ] wall man people sleeping and god
damn
but i started hearing this voice you
know that one the one i think i may have
told this years ago but
i was in a bus stop uh when i'd go to i
went to
cleveland state university and i take
the bus downtown every day to go to
school
for college and uh i was sitting in the
bus stop middle of winter
cold as [ __ ] man i just want to get on
the bus and go home and it's a miserable
ride back up to uh parma and this this
black guy comes in with like you know
jaundice
yellow eyes and he's got like no teeth
and he rests
it's always tedious and that's the
whistles through there hey man what's up
man
and it's one of those glass and clothes
[Laughter]
it's a glass enclosure those those bus
stops that are enclosed like that and
he puts one of his feet up against the
back of the glass
starts banging it as hard as he can so
now the whole thing is shaking
and he looks at me and he goes how's it
feel to be in the last days of living
[Laughter]
i said what do you mean i said what do
you mean and he says
what you want it to mean that's what i
was dealing with that's where that voice
comes from that voice is
[ __ ] i've never had an issue with
that voice
when i would do stand-up in fact i had a
lot
of black people husband and wife fam
people will come up to me and they would
let me say you real you are from
cleveland
that's amazing it was not considered
racist now
it's very tricky in my voice over world
to navigate that
because it's like you're not allowed to
do it and i'm like i get it but like i'm
i'm honestly it comes from a place of
great love like that guy i could do that
guy all day man it's a fun guy
oh i would sit and talk man i would have
him
oh man you know the one thing i love is
i sit on my front porch
and i just have some honeydew man you
know this frying sickle
he hit this [ __ ] on talking some
[ __ ] man some black [ __ ]
well i have talked to that guy for hours
back home i really
that's you know so
oh usually these two teeth for some
reason they make it
you know what i mean how do they stay
all the other shit's gone but usually
the ones the one thing my mama told me
always take care of your front teeth
just those two just those two
i could open [ __ ] with these i mean
hand me a can of beans watch this [ __ ]
whoa
darnell rolo
rolo so i so i'm rifling through my
dad's [ __ ] to find a porn magazine wait
are we talking about your stepdad
my stepdad i'm looking for my stepdad
[ __ ] yes
and i see an envelope top drawer of his
dresser i see an envelope that says my
my real father's name on it now is his
last name thompson no
it's not no i don't know if i should say
the last thing no don't i'm not going to
say
yeah because these people you know
they'll find them they'll find it i
found your real fighter
it'll take 10 minutes get a 20-page
email
i want you to know i located your family
and i took the liberty of adding them on
facebook
and i made a photoshop of you with your
dad
i'm just trying to be nice i'm just here
to help
[Laughter]
those are the fans i had my yeah just
here to helpers
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor ritual
we deserve to know what we're putting in
our bodies and why
especially when it comes to something we
take every day rituals clean
vegan-friendly multivitamin is
formulated with high quality nutrients
in bioavailable forms your body can
actually use what you won't find
are sugars gmos major allergens
synthetic fillers and artificial
colorants
look i take this every day i'm always
looking for a multivitamin to take
forever i've been looking for it i've
been reading about these
one a days you take they have salt dust
and all this other stuff in it all right
these
are legit okay a multivitamin should
contain key nutrients and forms your
body can actually use
to help fill gaps in the diet no shady
extras i've been taking these now for
i think this is three months now and i
love it uh rituals delayed release
capsule design delivers high quality
nutrients including vitamin d3 and just
two daily
pills ritual is made traceable you'll
always know what nutrients you're taking
and where they come from thanks to
rituals one of a kind visible supply
chain
ritual is designed with your life stage
in mind get key nutrients without
the bs ritual is offering my listeners
10
off during your first three months visit
ritual.com
honeydew to start your ritual today our
next sponsor is stitchfix
uh now you guys know online shopping can
be overwhelming you never know if things
will fit returns are difficult you don't
even know what store to start with i get
stuff and i get home it's got this
little weird tag on the back or or the
back's way longer than the front
i'm always super picky about that stuff
so this season
let stitch fix do all the hard work
stitch fix offers clothing hand selected
by
expert stylists for your unique size
style and budget
every piece is chosen for your fit and
your life and it's the easy solution
to finding what makes you look and feel
your best
try on pieces at home before you buy
keep your favorites
and send back the rest stitch fix has
free shipping
easy returns and exchanges and a prepaid
return envelope
is included there's no subscription
required all right so you can try stitch
fix once
or set up automatic deliveries you'll
pay just a 20 styling fee for each box
which gets credited toward pieces you
keep and there are no hidden fees
ever alright stitch fix has styles and
clothing to fit any occasion for women
men and kids they ship
all over the u.s and they're available
in the uk
as well get started today at
stitchfix.com
honeydew and you'll get 25 off when you
keep
everything in your fix that's
stitchfix.com
honeydew for 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix
stitchfix.com honeydew
now let's get back to the duke so i
found this envelope with my real
father's name on it um
and i open up the envelope and inside is
a tiny piece
a little square piece of paper that's
been cut out of a newspaper
and it's the obituary notice oh [ __ ]
that's how i found out my dad died so
they had me
how long how long it must have been
recent recently
i used i thought i got really mad and i
didn't know how to bring it up to my mom
like what did you say yeah so did you
bring it up right away i had to figure
out a way to bring it up without being
like so i was looking for
something to check off too
you know i'm just trying to jerk off
just trying to come and you find out
your dad's
so i'm mopping up at kmart one night and
these three girls come in and they say
they're lost
and i say okay i'm gonna help you out
next thing i know they're sucking my
dick
page two you know but i'm like i'm just
trying to find
you know a dirty magazine so i i just
basically i said i was looking for a i
thought one of my socks had gotten in
there or something you know because you
you were forbidden to go in that room
don't go in there josh
he had it amazing penthouse was like
it was an amazing time yeah and that was
the dirty one too oh yeah
but girls peeing in cups and [ __ ] like
that
no you're thinking of it was close no
you're thinking of like uh
you're talking like wee and swank
penthouse was peeing
all over the place were they peeing all
over i didn't we didn't have those
[Applause]
[Laughter]
one time my buddy joe and i oh my mom
i was such a stupid [ __ ] kid i i uh
would get dirty magazines from the older
guy his name was greg
and he worked at subway sandwiches and
salads with me when i was 15. yeah that
was my first
was that what it was back in the day it
was sandwiches and salads
subway sandwiches and salads and then
have subway maps on the wall like this
is a new york thing meanwhile it's like
the shittiest meat you know
but i worked there andy and robbie
saradacas were this greek couple
it was a franchise they ran it come here
josh you're a good boy
and uh andy would always say uh all
right mind the start josh i got
i got a meeting meanwhile the meeting
was down the street at the broadview
tavern
you know now he's down there drinking
come back smelling like a bottle of
you know a good boy a good boy that's
when he'd be real nice to you after he
was drinking
but uh greg the older guy would always
score me
dirty magazines so i had a nice
collection going in my bottom drawer
and one night after school got back from
high school
real tired i decided to read a little
swank
and i fell asleep on it i had the
magazine open oh [ __ ]
and i just fell asleep on it and i wake
up and i feel like a slight tugging
under my head
and i don't really know what's going on
i wake up i look up and there's my mom
and she doesn't know yet what she's
pulling out it could be a comic book
could be cracked magazine you pressured
my face
and then she and as soon as she oh oh
joshua you know it's a sin against the
church oh my god
so then she makes my dad throw out his
[Laughter]
magazines
so but she threw him in the garbage can
and a couple days before that my dad had
thrown
a dead raccoon in this garbage can oh
man
so now the magazines are on top
of a maggot infested raccoon carcass
that did not stop me and my friend joe
yeah hormone ain't nobody
dressed all in black i don't know why
because it was my own front yard we
dressed all in black it was the summer
of uh
you know 88 87. we led a reconnaissance
mission
out to the garbage can and took those
magazines
and kept them we we divided them among
ourselves and we kept them it was a
beautiful
that's a good score yeah man it was
pretty exciting swank club
hustler you know so uh
i found out that my real father was gone
and i i it just
it really broke me in half because i
would it was like oh
and i'll never get a chance to did you
think at the time you ever would
so you were building you were hoping you
would yeah i thought maybe you know i
bet someday i'll meet him
someday i'll reach out and meet him
and it just was it it was like but you
never tried to call that number in the
card after that or anything like that to
get a hold of him
i did you did [ __ ] yeah but listen i
just want to say something real quick i
hope you know what he passed from
because genetics are everything when it
comes to health and we're getting older
you should look into that [ __ ] dude i'm
just saying that i want to say that's
thrown
out too you should my mom says this to
me this is last year
after all this time i'm almost 46 and my
mom says
i said yeah mom uh i'm gonna go oh no
that's when i had an operation i had a
double
uh i had a hernia i had a double
what is it an inguinal hernia so they
had to do both sides
and just before the surgery they were
like you have any history of anything i
said mom
there's nothing in our family you go oh
actually no your real father had a
you know heart heart condition oh that's
good
thank you very much what the [ __ ] now
they're wheeling
what she might not make it
that's the kind of [ __ ] you gotta know
that's my listen if your parents [ __ ]
hate you and you ain't talk to them or
you don't know them for any reason
just trying to get their health records
that's all you really need family
secrets yeah don't keep that a secret
that's the one thing so
high school i'm about to graduate from
high school and i went to catholic
school
um and uh you got to understand
that this was 19 early 1990s
in cleveland in the midwest
and that's important for what i'm about
to tell you because what i'm going to
tell you right now is no big deal now i
tell this to people like
okay yeah who cares but at the time my
mom
picked me up from school one day
unannounced i
i was like what what's that that wasn't
normal not normal at all yeah
she said uh i just wanna i wanna talk to
you about something i said okay
so she had mcdonald's that was the
weight of my heart
well apparently not actually now that i
know about the heart condition it was
kind of a real [ __ ] up thing for my
mom
to do trying to kill me big mac you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
go ahead wash that down with a jug of
sugar
a little prick oh so we go to a park
she takes me to one of the parks we're
sitting i'm like what's going on she's
like well
i got to tell you something about your
father
he's not dead you know is it were you
lying about that i don't know what it's
gonna be
and she says um well you know he died
he died he had a they said brain tumor
she said he died of a brain tumor do you
know how old he was
30. whoa 36. oh holy [ __ ]
very that's weird too i've outlived my
father me
same yeah i had a weird time with it
it's weird i'm
it's weirder right now for me as i'm you
know about to be older than your dad
i'll never feel older than him i say it
all i know it's weird but i'll never
feel like i'm not
his son and i'm younger right no i don't
know that's i get it yeah i feel that
way and and
she said you know he was uh he moved to
san francisco
to he moved to the bay area when you
were very young
because he was gay okay now
when you're going to a catholic school
in the midwest
and that bomb has dropped on you it was
a huge [ __ ] deal
it's not a big deal at all now at all
in any way no but at the time it was
like
am am i am i gay i don't know how this
works
right we didn't know how it worked so
all i know is that there was a service
for him
here in cleveland there was a service
for him but i think he was
he was either buried or his ashes were
scattered in san francisco
and it wasn't until oh and then
and then several years after that
my mom gives me an envelope
that is written on the front of the
envelope it says to be given
no poems about josh
by his father to be given to josh when
he's 21. now i don't know what kind of
[ __ ]
arbitrary age that was i don't know
whose wish that was
but i got this envelope of
poems that my dad had been writing
over the years as i was growing up no
bro but i'm also assuming he
like no one expects to be dead at 36
right
so at some point you're he's alive when
you get these and then maybe that's the
beginning of
this next chapter for you guys what what
what kills me and you're a father so
this is really
imagine if
i mean i'm not even a parent and it
makes me really sad to think about this
like you can no longer see your child
and you're writing letters to them that
are not getting to them
you're hoping they do but there's this
intermediary
channel my dad would send it to his mom
and then his mom would send it to my
grandmother
my mom's mom and then somewhere along
the way it
it it wouldn't get to me so they were
holding on to this
maybe by his wishes to maybe 21. that's
probably what i think okay but i'm gonna
read you one you brought him yeah
i can't wait josh robert thompson came
prepared
i just want you to know the last time
jeremiah walked
from girl we had a [ __ ] tear
we get the get the uh tissues here we go
get them ash but i'll do it as morgan
freeman all right okay
is this let me ask a quick question is
this the first one you ever read
right here yeah okay so this is the
first one
in that stack yeah it's this is really
no matter what voice you use right now
in your own thoughts you read this man's
word it's the first communication you've
ever had that's exactly it but the
communications coming from your
head reading this this is another this
is him speaking to me
yeah this is the first time you've ever
communicated yeah and it's from beyond
it wasn't it meant to be i'm guessing
right 36
but this is the first time you've ever
yeah it's not like he's dead it's not
like by the time you read this
i will be longer yeah yeah yeah you have
inherited nothing
good luck you have inherited a bad heart
you'll most likely get your ass kicked a
lot as a kid
so here's here's the first one this is
from 1985. this is from your father
as narrated by morgan that's right
joshua i'm a little lonelier today
it's your birthday oh this is so sad
it's sadder morgan freeman's voice 10
years old
wow i'm missing you yes
today a bit more
dude i mean i can't even this guy's
sitting here
writing this got no way to see me
and and and you know and who knows about
the gay thing and not was he in the
closet was he being tortured
by his own sexuality as well as being
not being
that's correct man this is what i have
so much going on
this and he's a young man this really
opened my eyes
to what it must be like
to grow up you know in the lgbtq
community feel like you're different and
especially you gotta imagine man growing
up in cleveland
when he was in the 70s when he he was a
kid
i mean it had to have been rough to keep
that a secret i mean he you know he got
married he got i mean he got you know he
was
you know what you were supposed to do
back then yeah and they were kids i mean
there were
20 and they were both art students that
that's how my mom met my
my real father they were art students
together they went to art school
together he was an artist
he was a painter and in fact he went to
san francisco and had a bunch of big art
shows
you know he did it he did his thing but
i can't imagine
um i don't know what his relationship
was like with his father i mean i never
met
his father's father died a long long
time ago but i know it wasn't the best
and like a big italian family
i i don't know what it was like for him
i'm still piecing the piece putting all
the pieces together but
here's uh i want to ask real quick um
well i just lost my my question but it's
i'll come back to it go ahead i don't
want to stop your your post hitler had
smoked too much that day
he was back
it finally caught up with him not only
could he not remember the question he
was going to ask
he didn't know how to get home after the
show
uh no here's one um this is from there's
no data on this
there's no date it says happy birth
happy birthday in just six days
it's entitled void uh
i missed you before i miss you now
yet i like tuna fish sandwiches
especially
if i could share them with you i don't
know why
is that
i was like tuna fish i don't know [ __ ]
maybe peanut butter jelly
is this my dad man that one killed me
though
just this image of this guy just
cheering yeah sitting next to you and
splitting it i see it from the back too
i see the sandwich hand
that's uh man and you're so
i want to i got my question yeah are you
in a box
like are these presented to you and
you're just reading one after the other
yeah
in this moment yeah holy [ __ ] and i
don't know what to
and how long after he died you said
about six years well because you're 21
the last one
this is this is maybe you know when it's
dated
it is yeah i do and it's five months
before he dies five months
i also want to ask you and this is
another question uh if you have a
picture of him and do you look like him
we'll come back
yeah i will um november 89.
so i'm 14. yeah november 27th 1989. okay
so this team
wow so i was four i was 14 years this is
this is what's [ __ ] up too is this is
holidays
thanksgiving christmas going right
around the corner and he's sitting there
yeah on thanksgiving by himself i don't
know
who he's got with him to hold you just
once
what color is your hair now mom is
trying to get a picture of you
she talked to your grandmother yesterday
it's my mom's mom
no matter i see you as a young gentleman
hope you are talented
that one [ __ ] gets me oh if only he
i wish he could see what i had you know
what i did yeah you know
your grandma says you are very good in
writing
good good i hope i read some of it i
love you joshua
i hope i get to see you november 89.
damn that was it and you what did you
say he passed though you're not sure
well so they told me it was a brain
tumor
here's where the story gets very
emotional because i finally made that
phone call
i got a phone number from my mom that
said the italian
family and it said uncle joey
call you he call you [ __ ] uncle joey
you call me who the [ __ ] is this
that's what i would be thinking you yeah
that's exactly how my family went here's
me
you playing a [ __ ] joke don't [ __ ]
with me you're talking about my brother
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah this is uh no i'm his son i i i
make this phone call i call this guy
uncle joey
okay so you don't call that number from
the card years ago
okay this is a new number new person
yeah all right
uncle joey and he's like holy [ __ ]
who i know it's josh joshua i'm like
that's
i'm you know i'm your brother's son
oh my god he's like i can't you know did
he know
yeah okay they did wow how
you know i said love someone be in town
where are they including they're all in
cleveland okay
so i'm gonna be in town and uh
i'd like to meet you guys oh [ __ ] you
know
so i mean now uh
now i'm hearing from well he's the
liaison so uncle joey was
all right i set up for you no problem
tell you what meet us over at the deli
you know on third street over on you
talk about that thing run it back
don't bring anybody come by yourself
park three blocks down and walk over
there
don't wear a jacket or nothing you're
gonna get patted down at the night none
of this but
i met him at a nursing home because my
grandmother
the woman that had been trying to get a
hold of me all these years the woman
who apparently her heart was just broken
in two that one of her grandchildren
i can't she could never see him again
right
so she did get to see you at some point
well i went to the nursing home
to meet everybody they wanted me to meet
them there and it was like our lady of
you know the lifted chair or whatever
no i mean
look at a chair it's lifting it's a
[ __ ] miracle do you remember the
miracle of a lifted chair in a bible
so it's a beautiful place beautiful
place man i mean it's right out of
you know everything you think about the
catholic church i mean he's a real
devout catholic attempt and who are you
meeting who's in attendance when you
have
everybody uh you know
my two aunts his sister my aunts i'm
from cleveland me two aunts
i i remember the black people in
cleveland they would say auntie
they're they're proper about it auntie
my auntie
they'll be like hey man well first of
all man this [ __ ] only money and
i'm tired of his [ __ ] me
talking to [ __ ] man
you know but tomorrow man i got to go
down the street because i'm about to
visit my auntie
[Laughter]
so my my two answer there uh
joey i mean their kids their spouses
then all these grandkids i walk in dude
i walk into this room i walk into this
facility into a big room
like a ballroom area almost all these
people are looking at me
and then they say one of them my aunt
says hold on a minute i'll be right back
got someone i want you to meet and then
she pushes this wheelchair out
and there's this little sweet old lady
who can't talk
because she's had a stroke oh so she
can't even speak to me
and she looks up at me and she starts to
just
cry and she i don't know how she
communicated with my aunt but she had
indicated somehow that i looked
just like her son my father
and it was like seeing him again because
i had grown a beard out a little bit and
she was like i mean bittersweet
too he's gone and now here you are and i
don't know who i am to any of these
people i don't know who they are to me
and it was and i i all i could do was
just embrace this woman
and uh it was like my only link to this
man
and um and then a year later
now his was his brother there at that he
was okay
and what was that like i mean i i i
don't i don't i really just remember
that part with my grandma but there was
a lot of
it was all a blur people are just
shaking my hand hey dawn i'm
uncle pino i'm cousin vinnie and you're
like i
i don't i guess i'm an [ __ ] from
hollywood i feel like such a douche you
know i got like a suit coat on
people are wearing browns jerseys oh i
gotta get all dressed up this [ __ ]
guy
they're already starting in on me that's
great and uh
but i think it must have been maybe a
year or two later that uh
that that my grandmother was dying
and uh i went back to cleveland
and i visited her in the hospital
and i sat with this woman that i don't
know
and i held her hand in that hospital
that's nice you know
she didn't you know she passed away not
long after that
but i just felt like it was something i
had to do
and now last just last year that family
sent me a box of my friends stuff yeah
well my fa my family that fan those
people those [ __ ] people over there
you know my fam we don't really i mean
we we stay in touch here and there
yeah well there's all different kinds of
relationships and families
there just are some paid dividends years
and years down the road and so what did
they send you
well they sent me a box of just a lot of
his things i guess they were cleaning
out
grandma's house or someone else had been
living there for a while and they were
finally gonna i don't know what the deal
was but
pictures someone else was in here like
get this [ __ ] out of it hey man
what is this [ __ ] doing in here man
trying to visit my auntie it means
nothing to them and everything
some [ __ ] man all these scribbles
and [ __ ] who cares about this man
i threw half a mile hey rolo burn all
this [ __ ]
rolo rolo you [ __ ]
so no man it was all it was a lot of his
artwork
and uh and there were uh sketchbooks
and i started leafing through it some of
his high school sketchbooks
his drawings looked exactly like the
ones i do because i'm an artist no i
draw
you know cartoons and stuff and then a
style like this
yeah it's very similar yeah wow which
was interesting to me it was crazy
i'm like this is crazy and then i came
and then the one thing that really got
me was a picture of him
uh in san francisco is a picture of him
standing with all these other guys i
imagine this was his
group of guys he hung out with and they
were at a bar or a restaurant i don't
know but
i looked at this guy in this photo and
he looked so
happy and i thought
he [ __ ] did it like he he found his
people
even for a short while he found his
people
and he found happiness he made it out of
cleveland and our journeys were similar
in that sense where i i
you know the the key here is to get the
[ __ ] out of cleveland i think is what
we're seeing
the ravens
did lebron leave again is he back
the key is to leave no but he did it man
he did it
like and and i realized uh you know he
had an art show and
it wasn't the biggest art show in the
world but none of that [ __ ] matters i
used to put so much importance on like
you got to be in the biggest movies you
you didn't [ __ ] know he made it he
did it
he did it and i did learn that you know
he died of aids
which i assumed i don't know why how'd
you learn
they told me uh my aunt told me she did
at that reunion your auntie she was like
my auntie
she was like and of course you know he
died of age and i'm like worse like that
of course i just
spit that out it's got heart problems
anything else i should know about his
aids hereditary
yeah can i get aids 20 of you have it
[ __ ] so is there anything from this
keepsake box that you um have
prominently displayed in your home or
you know what that's amazing you asked
me that
my therapists this is what i do bro but
honestly dude
my therapist just asked me that two days
ago how long you been seeing this
therapist
about two years
wait even an hour bro the honeydew
if you're looking to get therapy for
free come to the honeydew
dr sickler's gonna put you in shape
sickles they call you sickle cell it
wasn't a [ __ ]
few people do yeah that's funny
christina that whole crew they all
because
it's the worst day i just saw somebody
tweeted that today and i was like he
ain't faking that's a delivery driver
[Music]
my whole family got this [ __ ] uh
the one pic i think the picture of him
with uh
all those friends because you have it up
i'm gonna put that's the one i'm gonna
frame i mean and who has picture i mean
it's weird like we all have pictures on
our phones i mean i remember as a kid
where everyone had framed pictures
everywhere i do i don't have any because
i don't have anybody in my life i have
nothing
so put that next to the picture of my
cats you should put that picture
no i should man because because
uh that's a reminder of like after the
late late show when the late late show
ended
i really had this idea of what was
supposed to happen after that show
i had these expectations of how like
this is a springboard
everyone's going to know me now the
industry's going to go
there's the guy that was jeff the robot
not
not one [ __ ] person
nobody i was the wrong i mean i spent so
much i'm the robot
don't know what that means good luck get
in line family guy for how many years
10 years 10 years yeah 10 years but when
you're a voice actor you're always
i guess that's part of the gig you're
just trying to convince people that but
most voice actors
act with their voice right and they have
a window and a range
higher level you are just i mean you're
a swiss army knife you're so [ __ ]
dynamic it's like
yeah but you're right you can't do
certain things anymore
but where are they gonna find rallo i
mean they're really gonna go
casper hey man are they really gonna go
fine this happened on
um one of the show one of the shows i do
this happened they called me and said
hey man
because i do morgan freeman a lot and
they said
we got a note that we're going to have
to recast the morgan freeman
and i was like you [ __ ] talking about
morgan freeman knows i do it
yeah we know we love you but you know
you're white i'm like dude i'm not doing
it i'm doing the voice of another person
he yeah he's not a race not a generic
what i think black people
asian people white people sound like
it's i'm imitating
that's exactly right and so okay and
then
and they had they held auditions for two
weeks
all right so anyway never mind uh that's
gonna be another year yeah
but i you know
it made me it that this story of my
father makes me appreciate my life and
what i have
and it's it's okay to aspire to want
more of course of course unless you're
from cleveland then keep it on it down
low
don't tell anybody about it but
i i look at his life and i think geez
you know
he had these amazing i have all these
photos of his art gallery shows and he's
all dressed
up and he's happy as can be and you know
he found his place in the world
and like i said if but for a short while
none of it doesn't [ __ ] matter it
doesn't you don't have to
be the biggest star in the universe just
be happy
and the takeaway is just make what you
want to make
do what you want to do don't worry about
the likes and the favorites and the
you know and and i got into after the
late late show i got into like social
media stuff and
fighting with trolls for years years
just like
you know i i've had five drinks
i could go to sleep or i could go live
for five hours and yell at people i
think i'll do that five hours
i think i'll do that but i realized that
the trolls
and all the i would do this live stream
do live streaming a lot way back in the
day before facebook was doing it
this was like early days none of us knew
what the [ __ ] we were doing
and uh i realized that all the people
that i would get into it with the people
that would say horrible things like
you suck you're a has been you're washed
up you're a loser you're nobody it's
like
the reason i was upset is because yeah i
i think that about me you can't [ __ ]
say that about me
right you know it's that thing of like i
hate my dad yeah your dad's an [ __ ]
[ __ ] you man don't say that about him
so i realized i was it was like i was
going back to the playground again
mentally
back in time to that school urban
community school
and like feeling like i guess that's
what i deserve i guess it's over
like i thought the late late show was a
fluke thing like i was on that show for
eight years
god you've had good runs just a lot of
things if you never do anything again
if you'll never do anything in your life
ever again
you're 40 you know you outlived your dad
what the [ __ ] else do you want
you know your dad died at a very young
age granted it was from aids but
granted it was if you do nothing else
ever in the history of your life
you should be grateful and i am grateful
i'm
i love it it was an amazing show to be a
part of i loved working with craig and
we went on tour for years
yeah but the way that show ended
was so horrible like it was the most
painful thing i'd ever gone through in a
job
why is that how did it go i mean it was
like
did you have a heads up craig called me
like
six or seven months before the show
ended and he's like so listen man so
here's what we're gonna do
so i'm on the set of a show and i'm
making
a shitload of money but anyway you're
going to be fine man
you know i just want to let you know
that i'm stepping down
and you know but you'll be taken care of
man we'll tour and everything so
it was really nice of him to do that
like he was he's on a set of hot and
cleveland
the show that they did a while back
betty white and everyone so he was a
guest star on there and
he called me while they were doing his
makeup just to let me know this is
what's up and i was like thank you man i
really appreciate that
and um you know
when the show ended
uh the second to last show he had me
come out during the beginning of the
show
and entered introduced me as this is the
guy
that did the voice of jeff the robot you
know i i jeff the robot for
most people who don't know was a talking
skeleton
like an ed mcmahon yeah that sat at this
lectern
and i puppeteered jeff you know i
actually moved his
body and his arms and his mouth
everything and then i had all these
musical instruments backstage
and i would make all these noises and
then i'd also make the phone on craig's
desk ring
there was a button on the floor i pushed
with my foot and i was all the callers
on the phone
so i was doing all these voices there
was a lot of [ __ ] going on back there
um you know and he finally he brought me
out and was like
what do you do for a living the video is
on youtube but uh
i said um you know i do the voice of
jeff peterson and he's like
[ __ ] standing ovation and i got a
little nervous
because nice i don't want it to go on
too long
yeah i'm like like you know like cause
it's that thing like i would open for
craig you know i would tour with him and
he he'd ask right before he'd go on he'd
be like how are they man
how were they and you go they were good
they're good
you don't want to be like they were
[ __ ] great man they were eating out
of the palm of my hands
they loved me they [ __ ] thought i was
the best you just wanna you know so i
i had that nervousness about it um but
it moved me
man it really was like people finally
got to see me
yeah and that's why i thought this is
going to lead to some big stuff
at the end of that taping craig got in
his car and i think
went to the airport went back to
scotland
i went next door with all the crew and
we had a goodbye party
at the uh what is it the wood ranch
restaurant you know right next to cbs
television city and by the way
this was an amazing job for me because
television city has such history
oh yeah carol burnett show and all in
the fans and we still got the prices
right in there and
price is right right below us so i'm all
about old tv history and it was
it was such an honor to be on that show
i mean we got away with everything dude
we just showed up and made [ __ ] up
everything we did on that show for the
most part was
just improvised we never planned
anything right yeah you know
and but
he left town i got really shit-faced
at this farewell party and we all said
our emotional goodbyes
and then early the next morning i got a
call from cbs
and i'm hungover and they said you need
we need you to come get your [ __ ]
basically i was like what are you
talking about well uh
you have stuff in your office still i
said yeah i was just coming on monday
this was like
like the weekend yeah we need you to
come get your stuff like in the next
hour okay because
uh the james corden show that's the next
guy that took over for the late late
show
uh his people are here they're
renovating the office and they
they need to knock the wall down
there's a guy standing by with a
sledgehammer you need to come get your
[ __ ]
oh okay so i'm hungover i'm already sad
and emotional about the end of this show
this and you don't like this robot
no one knew that this was gonna happen
craig no one knew that this
dynamic between he and i between the
robot and craig
was going to become the biggest part of
the show
at the end of its run i mean you could
not separate the two
craig had a lot of like sound machines
and little gadgets that he'd have
throughout the years but he got bored
with all of them
so when the robot came along we i just
assumed he would do it for a couple
weeks
and then he'd get rid of it and then
somehow
it just we struck gold so like it was
it was this really special thing that we
never knew would
become what it was so to have it go out
that way
so i show up i walk by the sound stage
where
our studio was and it was completely
empty
this crew amazing crew they had already
dismantled
the entire thing there wasn't one stage
there was nothing
damn i was like oh it's like that
went up to my office and there were
there was a crew standing by
you guys is this your office yeah all
right we need you to get this stuff out
of here we got a uh
got one of these metal roller uh little
flatbed things just go ahead and roll
your [ __ ]
so you remember the end of indiana jones
and the raiders of the law stark the
very end of that movie
the ark of the covenant is boxed up in a
crate yeah and there's this weak old guy
just wheeling it through this warehouse
and the camera's pulling back like this
and there's this box that was me
josh hunched over the cart pushed his
wares down a long
hallway into an elevator and up another
flight of stairs
three long trips three long trips filled
with memories
three of them three dude you know why
because the wall
the wall in my office was covered with
all the fan art and letters
and props and amazing things that people
sent to me over the years
and i had to box this all up but like
quick like imagine the guys
come on man we gotta go so
i i put it all in my car and uh the last
thing i heard as i was wheeling out of
there was i'm starting to knock that
wall down
and that was like an ominous like
this is a taste of like what's to come
for you you know and um
honestly now you know it was a weird
history for me with that because we did
comic con a couple times
with the late late show and they said
jeff the robot's gonna be a comic-con
and i was like this is [ __ ] great i
mean i
i loved being on that show that was the
greatest gig
it was like the dream gig for me because
ever since i was a kid i would build
like
talk show sets in my basement out of
cardboard and my friends were always my
guests
johnny car was a big fan of johnny
carson yeah which by the way i remember
my grandfather uh craig and i had toured
and made our way through cleveland
that's always fun
performing in front of your entire
family yeah they had shown up at the
cleveland rock ceno it's a hard rock
roxino
and i don't know who was there i just
know that a lot of my family members
showed up and um did the stand up
the sad thing is i think i heard from
two people after that
i don't i didn't hear from anybody else
so i was like i don't know if anybody
showed up
two years later at my i'm at my
grandfather's 90th birthday party he's
90 years old in his own house at his
birthday
my grandfather pulls me aside a man in
his 40s
and says you know i was at that uh
stand-up show you did a few oh
you were cause i had no idea because you
never mentioned it remember
dream of my life grandson growing up
entertainer he goes yeah um
a piece of advice from an old man uh
maybe don't use such vulgar language
maybe don't work blue and he's like you
know guys like red skelton
and johnny carson i go johnny carson
beat the [ __ ] out of his wife
he didn't work pluto all right yeah
right anyway so
cosby work clean too right yeah so this
i did i
have yourself going drinking bought but
uh you know i so i
i loved old tv and i was so honored to
be a part of that show and we made
something really special it was just
that i wished
more people knew that i was the guy
so when we went to comic-con it was a
huge thing man i'm going to meet fans
going to sign autographs here we go
so people lined up
there were thousands of people lined up
to talk to jeff peterson
so jeff the robot was there i was in the
booth
you know with the monitors i could see
people hi how are you i'm jeff peter oh
man people light up you know
and i said so can i go out and uh meet
meet everybody and they said
uh no we we got a directive from the
network
um that you got to stay inside the booth
and i was like but that doesn't make
sense comic con is about you know people
come to meet
you know like robert downey jr doesn't
walk around dressed as iron man right
yeah you come to see him
two years in a row they made me stay in
there and i couldn't come out and i
couldn't meet anybody
and so so how do you help yourself yeah
that
and so that's why and just saying this
to people out there
you know when i was going through a hard
time after the late late show you know i
did
get into it with people in live streams
and i feel bad about the people that got
caught in the crossfire i do there were
really good people that love this
character
i love the character i love the show
it's just that weird thing of like
i want you to know i was the character
but also i want you to
like the other things i do you know so i
got real angry for a while and i got
real bitter and it was a bad look for me
um but therapies you know definitely
help me out i'm probably gonna have a
heart attack soon
yeah genetically you're right you're
about to do but you know
but that you know there's so many more
stories about the late late show but
you know the guy that the guy that built
jeff the robot uh grant imahara he was
the guy from mythbusters you know he
oh really he actually built that yeah he
died he died um
i didn't know he died last year i don't
know sad man
from like getting an aneurysm oh man
really tragic you know
he's the guy that built that robot and
showed me how to puppeteer it
so he's as much a part of that as
anything i just wanted to mention that
because he was an amazing guy
and um you know but
you think about my dad's life and then i
think about other friends of mine i got
a friend right now
my friend my buddy matt matt lode he's
uh he's been a sports reporter in
cleveland for
for a year over 20 years he's an amazing
guy my best buddy
my best buddy in the world and we grew
up uh
we met in junior high we remained great
friends ever since
and uh he's been fighting stage four
lymphoma for the last couple years damn
and you look at this guy
and the way he conducts himself
it's mind-blowing to me that's what we
talked about like what am i
what am i complaining right right but he
we say that to ourselves but a guy like
that would never say that to you that's
right he would know what's your [ __ ]
problem right
this is a very religious guy he's a
hard-working guy i mean he has
i i can't even imagine what it's like
for him right now with all the therapy
he's had
the chemo and his wife is a saint she's
by his side every day you know he's one
of these guys you know his family lives
the house he grew up in his parents
still live there and it's like five
blocks down the street
you know i used to really kind of look
at that like
well you haven't even left i left and
went to another i lived in l.a you know
you haven't done anything and
and as you get older you go you know
doesn't matter it's not what it's about
man he's figured it out i think he
figured out more than i did
early on they did so i encourage people
to
um keep an eye out on my
website because we're about to have a
big fundraiser for him
all right and been talking to uh craig
ferguson about it we're gonna sell jeff
peterson
t-shirts okay all the money's gonna
happen that's the charity all of it
well when you have the link and
everything set up send it to us yeah
we'll try to include it into
i would love to have it up in the next
few weeks i will all right don't include
it in your um
ash can we make sure we do that yeah i
would love that you know
it's just anyway life is as you get
older
people you know friends and family
members start to die but some of these
you people not at our age you know we're
like like my friend raymond that i did a
bunch of public access tv with
uh he died he was 36. he's your dad age
your dad's age yeah yeah that's young my
dad was 42 and 36 sounds crazy to me i
mean he had uh he had that
um john ritter died from that aortic
dissection you know his heart just
and that one really that was the one
that was in 2016 that was the one that
like
pushed me over the edge yeah that's when
i kind of went to a dark place
and then brody obviously man you know
and i'll tell you a positive about the
social media that's how i met brody
stevens
he would watch my rants on live streams
right
they were funny i mean they were funny
they weren't all dark but he
watched and he was like i saw your rants
good stuff
you got it i got my brody [ __ ] in the
office right over there you got it yes
818 till i die
arms cross negative she gets it he gets
it
one of the funniest people in the world
that guy everything's been said about
him already but the comics comic i mean
watching that guy do his thing was the
funniest
uh examination of comedy he just turned
it on its head
and that's how we met and that's how i
did his show he had me come on the
festival of friendship
and we talked forever and
you know and he did his thing that's you
just got to remember these people did
their thing you just got to you got to
do what makes you happy
you know and don't are you happy now i'm
getting there
yeah i'm i'm right now uh
definitely happier than i've ever been i
don't say it too loud
you know cause covid oh i'm glad you're
doing well yeah i've been out of work
for six months you piece of [ __ ]
well if you never do anything
hey you know what we had that one
yeah yeah oh your mom died from covert
well you know if you never get another
mom
you know what i mean yeah at least you
had one right
[ __ ] you oh man
so i'm i'm all right i'm i'm in that
phase where not phase i'm in that
part of my life where i love voiceover i
love doing voiceover
but now to me it's a day job and it's a
great day job
it's the best [ __ ] day job it's a job
i'm not complaining about it let's get
the adjectives all these people that
want to call
date you know they all that you i'm
thank god i had a day job
i wrote and produced for years right if
i don't have that
skill or that ability i don't do that
yes i don't do all these people want to
demean by calling it a day just a
[ __ ] job well what i mean i guess
whatever
you also work a lot of jobs like all of
us do right i don't just work one
exam i'm doing ten [ __ ] things and
you're always having to find the next
thing the next thing
and what's next what's that's right but
here's the crazy thing
uh it's just not number one on my list
anymore it takes all the pressure off
number one on my list is and going back
to the letter that my
dad wrote to me number one on my list
has always been writing
so now when i read that letter recently
i was like holy [ __ ]
he's telling me yeah you're you're a
good writer
so i started writing i started writing a
book and you know it makes me very happy
and i would love to do that i would love
to you know filmmaking was my first love
i'd love to
make a film and and uh and it's
something that i'd like to shoot in my
old neighborhood which is something i've
been thinking about
oh my god you know maybe roll up put
rollo in there i mean come on dude
yeah awesome he's got to be in morgan
freeman will narrate all right so
this was a great episode i appreciate
you coming on
and opening up i want you to to before
i'm going to ask you about advice you
give your 16 year old self
and i want you to take us out of the
episode as morgan freeman okay
okay out of your story and out of the
episode all right
and then and go go ahead go ahead
so advice to my 16 year old self
you know if i was sitting across from me
at 16
knowing everything you just told us you
found you found out
and all joe not even joking when i say
this i would tell him
i would tell myself man you know here's
what you need to do
trust me on this get out of cleveland
[Laughter]
listen if you do nothing else nothing
else
no i would say um
do what makes you happy what the only
thing i can tell you is
do not worry or give a [ __ ] about what
anybody
says to you unless you are asking for
their advice
or they truly are your peers you know
that's it do whatever you want man
do whatever you want great and and and
really
do it for yourself first that's the key
because a lot of people are chasing the
likes and the views and i got to go
viral and but they're probably not going
to like no just
honestly make make work that is honest
and true to you man and like
do not worry about what anybody else
says trust me
that's great trust me and stay away from
girls
with tattoos above their asses
because sun no
so um plug everything you'd like to plug
again here
anything i just just go to my website
right now the
jrtshow.com the jrttjrtshow.com you're
your one-stop shop josh robert thompson
um douchebag i uh
i am so glad you came on thanks for
having me man of course
um take us out as morgan freeman and
i'll sign us
off well that's it for the honeydew
podcast
i hope you learned some [ __ ] i know i
did
dr sickler will be back with another
patient
next time until then this is morgan
freeman saying
get busy living or get busy dying
because hey if you do nothing else in
your life
at least you lived
you're the man uh as always i say ryan
sickler ryancical.com
we'll talk to you all next week
[Applause]
[Music]
you